tag eins ohne zucker wenige stunden ohne
das weiße gold und ich bin jetzt schon
fahrig und unkonzentriert und ich
vergesse dinge wo ist meine hose was
guckst du so blöd
ja ich bin auch zucker hinzu und was
dagegen [ __ ] und ich werde zunehmend
aggressiv durch unterzucker und versucht
mal in deutschland zuckerfrei zu leben
die schweine kippten das zeug überall
rein hier tomatensoße salatdressing
leberwurst selbst in zucker ist zucker
ich bin doch die hersteller dürfen den
zuckeranteil portionsweise angeben und
sie bestimmen wie groß die portion ist
laut packung sind eine portion komplex
30 gramm vor solch wissen wie für 30
grad sind da kommt doch noch die milch
dazu keine formel durch
hallo hallo drei tage und zucker ich
fange an dinge zu sehen kommt zurück ich
liebe dich doch
die universität hannover herausgefunden
kinder die zu viel zucker essen wird in
der schule schlechter
ich habe die ganzen supermarkt sucht nur
zwei produkte enthalten gar keinen
zucker zigaretten und salz abwickelt
blöcken noch alle gegen die zogajs
einfach keine chance man jetzt nächste
challenge lautet sieben tage ohne
brokkoli das fertig
was dann
martin tempo
[Applaus]